muestra de músculo el dimisionario
electoral más importante de brasil el
presidente ya ir bolsonaro y el
candidato luiz inácio lula da silva
presidieron sendas movilizaciones en sao
paulo ambos con visiones diferentes pero
estrategias similares bolsonaro entre
grupos evangélicos llamo a la lucha del
bien contra el mal también se refirió a
uno de los temas de actualidad el aborto
primero
este es un país que defiende la vida
desde la concepción es un país que aboga
por el respeto a los niños en las aulas
y por eso está en contra de la ideología
de género
[Música]
entre tanto lula que califica su campaña
como la lucha del amor contra el odio
arremetió contra el mandatario el trã
derechista el también expresidente acusó
al actual jefe de estado de promover el
hambre en el gigante suramericano vine a
sao paulo por el hambre 70 años después
y después de que el pp acabará con el
hambre en el país ahora 33 millones de
brasileños se van a dormir sin tener que
comer como se explica esto en un país
que es el tercer mayor productor de
alimentos del mundo y 85 días del
proceso electoral las encuestas no
favorecen a bolsonaro presenta una
desventaja entre 15 y 20 puntos ante su
adversario
mientras ambos líderes aseguraban apoyos
en sao paulo en brasilia la capital
cientos de personas marcharon al
congreso para exigir el libre porte de
armas según los manifestantes la marcha
apoyaba el derecho a la autodefensa y a
la seguridad